- Years ago when they
started this censoring thing
on Twitter, and on Facebook,
and on Google, and so on.
I said, "No, no, you
have to make regulations.
It's a new industry.
Every human interaction
is regulated by the law"
And conservatives were going,
"No, they must have
freedom of speech."
I thought, "Absolutely not."
You know, these
guys are basically,
what do they call
'em, common carriers.
They're like the phone company.
If I'm on the phone to you
and the operator comes on
and says, "Excuse me, sir,
you can't say that to Dave.
And Dave can't
respond," you know?
No, that guy gets carried away
'cause there's a
regulation against that.
We need to do that now.
We're just catching up with it.
I feel it's happening.
It may happen in the
Supreme Court session.
Certainly, there's
laws now in Texas,
that have been
supported by courts
where the court just said,
in Texas, "No, you know,
they don't have a right
to violate free speech."
It's a new thing.
Almost everything
we're going through
is traceable back
to the internet,
in the same way that everything
during the reformation
is traceable back to
the printing press.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is the
host of the Andrew Klavan Show
on The Daily Wire, as well as
author of the brand new book,
"A Strange Habit of Mind."
Andrew Klavan, welcome
back to the Ruben Report.
- Great to see you, Dave.
- Andrew, you've done many
things in your career.
Screenwriting, many
books, Daily Wire,
but you opened for me
during the "Don't Burn in
This Country" book tour.
Would you say that
was the highlight of
the whole operation?
And why even continue
working after that?
- I struggled with that question
after opening for your act.
I thought, you know, I'm
now so covered in shame
that maybe there's
no possibility
of going on with any
self-respect at all.
But I've managed a little bit.
- How many books
have you written?
Every time I bring you on,
I ask you how many books,
and I'm still not even
sure how many books.
It's a lot of books.
- Well, it's a lot of books.
The last book, when
they published it,
they said it was my 36th, so,
I'm just gonna go with that.
- Wow, I mean, that
is really something.
When you finish a book, do
you feel like it's your last,
and then suddenly there's
some more in the well,
or how do you feel usually?
- No, the, only time I
ever thought of giving up
was after writing a book
called "Empire of Lies,"
which was a very difficult book
and a very emotional book,
and it really wrecked me.
And I walked in and I said
to my wife, "That's it,
I'm done writing novels."
And she said, "Sit down
and have some dinner."
She didn't even believe me.
There wasn't even a
second where she thought
that I might be
telling the truth.
It's kind of like an addiction.
I can't stop.
- All right, so I wanna
get into the book,
so we just got a
copy this morning.
So in full disclosure,
I have not read it yet,
but I've read the synopsis here,
and obviously between big
tech, and billionaires,
and espionage, and
all sorts of stuff,
there's a lot that's relevant
to our political
stuff of the day.
So they'll be plenty
for us to talk about.
But first off, you, like
me and so many others,
are a California expat.
You are a refugee
of what is now,
I would say,
Communist California.
You're feeling pretty good.
Do people know publicly where
you live, sort of, roughly?
- Yeah, I'm in Virginia
in the DC area,
and yeah, it's the
smartest thing I ever did.
I mean, it was the zombie
apocalypse by the time we left.
I was living in the
Hollywood Hills,
which is a very
ritzy neighborhood.
And by the time I left,
I was patrolling my
backyard at night with a gun
to make sure nobody
had moved in.
You know, I had friends
who had found homeless
people in their apartments.
Friends who found them
in their backyard.
And, you know, it's nothing
against the homeless,
but it's nothing compassionate
about letting people
live on the streets.
It's not compassionate to them.
And it's not compassionate to
the people who come to a city
to find a way of life
that's, you know,
pleasant and uplifting.
I don't think you can do that
when your city is
overrun by people.
Not just homeless people,
but also criminals who are not
being restrained in any way.
It's just amazing to me.
It is absolutely amazing to me
that a state like California,
which is paradise, I mean,
if you take the people out,
it's just paradise, can be
destroyed at that level.
And yet people go on voting for
the people who destroyed it.
I once asked Larry Elder
why he thought that was so,
and he said, they
just don't connect
the policies to the apocalypse.
It's all policy.
I mean, New York was like that
in the '80s and '90s
when I lived there.
And then Giuliani came
in, changed the policies.
They called him a
racist every single day
in the New York Times.
He cleaned the city up,
and made it one of the
most beautiful cities,
one of the safest big
cities in the world,
if not the safest.
It took, you know, two years
to destroy all that work
that was kept in place by
Bloomberg all those years.
Took just two years of left
wing policies to destroy it.
It's hard to understand why
people will not turn the corner.
I don't know whether it's
the feeling of virtue
that leftism gives them,
but, I'm just so happy
to be out of that place.
It was absolutely disgusting
by the time I left.
- Do you see any hope,
because, you know,
we had a couple
dinners in LA before.
You left first, wisely,
and then I followed a
couple months later,
but all of our friends left.
And from everything I've seen
in basically the nine or so
months that I've been gone,
it's just getting worse.
I mean, how should we feel,
the people that leave?
Like should we feel, oh, maybe
they will turn it around?
Or should we be hopeful?
Or is it just like, you
know what, enough already,
that's what you guys want, then
just keep running with that.
- Well, you know,
I always hope it is one
of the United States.
I always hope that it'll
come back, you know, online.
And in the past,
because so much of the
industry is creative.
There's Hollywood and there's,
you know, Silicon Valley.
So these are people who are
creative, they're capitalists.
They like to pretend
they're not capitalists.
- So they can make
speeches at the Oscars
about not being capitalist,
but they're the most
capitalist people in the world.
And so when their
business gets undercut,
to a certain degree,
you think that they're
gonna come back and elect,
you know, a Reagan or a, you
know, even a Schwarzenegger,
somebody to sort of
change things up.
The problem now is that
because we live in a world
where we can be
connected like this,
like you and I are
connected right this minute,
there's not that much
difference if you leave,
you can build an
industry anywhere.
You can run an
industry from anywhere.
And so my concern is that
now people will simply move,
you know, to Nashville.
If you go to Nashville,
everybody there is from LA,
you know, people will
simply move to other places
and just let the place
sink into the sea.
You think eventually
the absolute destruction
of a brilliant economy,
will back up on them.
You know, it just,
you think that people
will only stand it so long,
and yet the fact that
they have stood by,
well, for instance,
San Francisco,
one of the most beautiful
cities on earth,
has been turned into a
hell hole, is just amazing.
It is just amazing.
So I don't know if
it's gonna come back.
- It's interesting because
more and more people
are talking about what
is the united part
of the United States of America.
You know, it's like,
I keep saying it,
but I honestly feel like I
moved to a different country,
not to a different state,
but to a different country.
And that I guess that
leaves us with the question
of what makes us united.
And I think there's a lot
of, you know, conservatives,
or whatever you want to call
broadly people on the right,
that are just like,
there's nothing left.
There's nothing
left, and that's it.
- Well, that is a thing
conservatives do, you know,
that's kind of a
knee-jerk thing.
Conservatives, "It's over,
it's all over, I give up,"
and all this, and you know,
when Roe v Wade was overturned,
I just reminded people, you
know, that things can change.
Amazing work can be done.
It takes a long time.
It took the left 60 years to
take over our institutions
and bring the country this low.
It's gonna be a long
fight to take it back,
but it can be done.
My hope is that we
become more federalists.
We let the states
interdependently
become laboratories
of democracy,
try different things,
and that as we do that,
the good ideas will spread.
The alternative
scenario to that is
we become more federalists,
we split apart,
and eventually we find ourselves
at each other's throats.
But I hope that's
not gonna happen.
In fact, one of the things
that I hope will help
is the repeal of Roe v. Wade.
I hope that because of that,
cultures are going to form
that attract and repel people.
And I think that, you know,
right now it's the economy.
People go places for the jobs,
they go places to get
away from the homeless,
and from the crime.
But soon people
are gonna go places
to live with other
people like themselves.
And as one way of living
works better than others,
I think maybe more states
will turn over, we'll see.
- You know, I should tell
you that here in Miami,
I did finally see one person
with a Charlie Crist sign,
and I almost knocked
on their door
and offered them free mental
health services for a year.
It's like, what are you doing?
You're here in heaven.
And you've got
a Charlie Crist sign.
- I know.
Yeah, that's the big fear,
that they'll bring
California with 'em.
- So we're taping this
just a little bit
before these midterms.
I mean, are you basically
feeling like this, you know,
"Conventional thinking is
Red Wave and the House,
and the Senate, they're
gonna get everything back,
win a couple governorships,
and then we'll reverse
all this Biden insanity."
Are you on board
conventional wisdom?
- No, I'm hopeful,
but I'm not certain.
I think we're gonna
win the House.
I think the House
looks pretty good,
but the Senate is really tough,
and it's a tough
map for one thing.
And then there's the
fact that, you know,
they keep blaming Donald Trump
for picking certain candidates,
Oz and Blake Masters,
and guys like that.
But the question is really,
is that the problem,
or is it that the GOP
won't support those people?
They seem to have pulled
money out of Arizona,
a very winnable state.
And I'm concerned that maybe
Mitch McConnell is thinking,
"I'd rather keep the minority,
and not have these people
come in and defy me,
and rebel against me."
Then let's take the Senate back.
Hard to really know.
First of all,
it's always hard to know what
Mitch McConnell is thinking.
It's hard to know where
his interests lie.
But at the same time, you know,
I also feel a little bit
like we're being gaslit.
The polls are telling
us no, you know,
the Red waves are coming back.
Nancy Pelosi is saying, "Oh,
we're gonna keep the house."
I wonder if we're being
gaslit a little bit,
and maybe the the red
wave will in fact appear
in spite of some of
the narrowing polls.
But I am concerned, I'd like
to see the Senate go back.
I think Donald Trump has
been incredibly selfish
with his money.
He's got something like
a hundred million dollars
that he has raised,
and seems to be keeping it
either for his legal fees
or for his next campaign.
And I think if you're gonna
be the leader of a party,
then you've gotta pour some
of that money into the races
that you, in fact, created.
You always worry with Trump
that he's only thinking about
getting personal revenge
for the people
who didn't support
his Stop the Steal movement.
I think Trump was a
really good president,
but I think he's been
a bad ex-president,
and I'm sorry about that.
I think it's hurting the party,
which needs to
reformulate itself
around some of the
things he taught them,
but can't do that as long
as he's getting in the way
instead of helping out.
- Is that your way of saying
you'd be sort of team DeSantis
if they have to make that
decision, ultimately,
for '24?
- I would love to see that.
I would love to
see DeSantis run,
and yeah, I would support him.
I wish that Trump were
the kind of person,
I mean, this is truly what
they call wish casting,
I wish he were the kind
of person who would say,
"I did my job, I
came in at my moment.
I changed things around,"
which he really did,
"and now I ordain that DeSantis
will inherit my
mantle and move on."
DeSantis is a kind
of mini Trump,
there's no question about it.
But he also is a statesman,
he's also a politician.
And one of the things people
like to say about Trump
is he's not a politician,
but that's a profession.
Being a politician
is a profession.
And, and you know, you
have to know how to do it.
You have to know how to
wrangle people and pass laws,
and not just past executive
orders that can be swept away
by the next guy with a pen.
- I know I can ask you
about the wokesters,
and the crazy
lefties all day long,
and we could do hours
and hours on it.
And I've watched your
videos on Instagram
where you watch videos of
them doing weird things
and all that stuff.
But let me ask you
one thing about that.
Because of someone,
as you mentioned,
you lived in the
Hollywood Hills,
you were in the Hollywood
machine as a screenwriter,
and as an author.
I'm guessing that you
probably had representation
with some of those
big organizations
and all that kind of stuff.
Did it feel like it
was gonna fall apart?
Did you always sense that it
would fall apart in that way?
I don't mean California
specifically,
but the industry,
and just the way the culture
war has just exploded,
because they decided to not
give us anything remotely honest
or reflective, of how
people felt about the world.
- Well, I was warning
about it for 20 years.
You know, I was saying
that it's not, you know,
we pour all this money
into some, you know,
house race in Ohio,
but we don't pour any
money into creating novels,
into creating movies,
into creating the infrastructure
that the arts need.
You know, everybody
is, on the right,
is celebrating the failure
of that movie, Bros.
But it's one thing to
celebrate failures of movies
that offend your sensibilities.
It's another thing to
make your own movies
and to also give
awards to artists,
and encouragement to artists,
and intelligent
reviews to artists.
Some of that's happening now.
It has been a long slow slog,
but yeah, you can vote
for people all you want,
but if you lose the culture,
this is the kind of thing
that's gonna happen.
And I've been thinking
as I read the news now,
and watch and things,
one of the greatest
arguments for Christianity
is that people who who lose
it, become utterly evil.
I mean, they're
butchering children
in the name of a weird
left wing gender theory
that has absolutely
no scientific backing.
They keep, you know, people
like Rachel Levine, you know,
who's, to me, a walking
Monty Python routine.
You know, he comes
out, he says things,
"Well, the data, the data."
And nobody ever says to
him, "Show me the data,
show me that," 'cause
there is no data.
There couldn't possibly be data
supporting the
butchering of children.
So what now?
- But Andrew,
They are the science.
That's why you're not
supposed to question.
They are science.
- You know, when Vladimir Putin
is screaming about the
satanism of the West,
Vladimir Putin, who I
think is a terrible,
terrible human being,
and an awful dictator,
and a colonialist,
and all these things,
but he's saying that,
and I'm thinking,"
Well, I have to agree
with him there."
He does have a point there.
So the culture is
really at a nadir,
and what I see coming forward
is basically a division
between people who opt
to be human beings,
and people who opt for
a technocratic world.
Eventually they'll
build synthetic wombs,
and women will actually
become obsolete as mothers.
And it's going to be
people who choose to say
"No, actually, women are
essential as mothers,
that mothers are
essential to our humanity,
and we cannot farm this
out to these technocrats."
And that's what I see in
the future, I'm hoping,
basically they'll give
me another 20, 30 years
so I can get outta here
and leave you guys.
You younger people
to deal with it,
but I do see that
coming eventually.
- Yeah, well that's sort of why
I was asking you the question,
about what do you want
to happen to California,
or what do you
think will happen?
Because I agree,
I think although we will
remain united in that,
I don't think we're
gonna have a civil war,
in some sort of
traditional sense.
I just think the the things
are just gonna diverge.
It just is what it is.
We've tried very
hard, sane people,
to reverse the wokesters.
They've made it very clear
they're not gonna reverse.
And unfortunately, the
institutions have shown
that they don't have the
defenses to defend against it.
So it's just gonna continue
to go in that direction.
- Yeah, and there's
the question of money,
because what happens in
leftism all the time,
and I guess we can
call this leftism,
it's some kind of
part of leftism,
is the middle class is
destroyed or moves away.
So you have the poor and
you have the powerful.
And that's what happens
every single time.
And that means that you
don't have a tax base.
And so in order to feed the
programs that keep you in power,
and keep the poor from coming
and burning your palace down,
you basically have to shift
money from other places.
And so you're gonna see a
move by the federal government
to try and take money
from prosperous places,
like Florida and like Tennessee.
and move it to places
that are dying of leftism,
like California.
And that's when the
clash is going to come.
And if that is prevented,
if that kind of shift of
the money is prevented,
then I don't know, I
just think things fail.
You know, leftism fails
everywhere it's tried.
Scandinavia, Russia, you know,
Cuba, everywhere it's tried,
it's much easier to enslave
in a little island like Cuba,
than it is to enslave Westerners
and people who have
a history of freedom.
- Listen, I can tell you,
in the very international
city of Miami that I'm in,
you meet a couple Venezuelans
and a couple Cubans,
and they will tell you what
that oppression was like.
But let's shift to
the book a little bit,
because as I said, we
just got it this morning.
I wanna read just one of
the bullet points on this,
'cause I thought this
was just fascinating
as I was just reading it
right before we started.
"The world of Big Tech is
full of eccentric characters,
but shamanic billionaire,
Gerald Byrne,
may be the strangest
of the bunch.
The founder of Byrner, a
global social media platform.
Byrne is known for speaking
with vague profundity,
and for dabbling in esoteric
spiritual practices.
He wears his hair in
a long black ponytail
to reveal a large flower
tattooed on his neck.
He's universally
admired as a visionary,
a philanthropist, and a
devout husband and father.
And every person who gets
in the way of his good work
seems to die."
Now,
(laughing)
there's a lot there, because
obviously I'm reading that.
The imagery of Jack
Dorsey from Twitter
is popping in my mind, with
his beard and weird things.
You know, we've got Elon Musk
and we've got the
Amazon guy, Jeff Bezos.
You know, there's this
weird billionaire class
of these sort of
strange characters.
How do you come up with
a character like this,
and who's it really based on?
(laughing)
- Oh, I couldn't
possibly comment on that,
but yeah, you know,
I think one of the things
that happens to billionaires,
and I've noticed this,
I've known a lot of billionaires
and they never stop talking.
They never listen
to a Word you say.
And they basically,
the principle is,
if you are so smart
why aren't you a billionaire?
Why should I listen to you
when I have a billion dollars?
And they sit around
and they really do make these
big plans for the world,
without anybody ever
saying to them, you know,
you invented a gizmo that
made you a billionaire
and that's great
and congratulations,
but what on earth
gave you the license
to control the lives
of other people?
You know, why are you flying
to Davos in your private jet
to discuss how much gas I
can use in my Volkswagen?
You know?
It's like, it's a
complete disconnect.
And so what I wanted to do, the
character of Cameron Winter,
who first made his appearance
in "When Christmas Comes,"
which we did talk about,
that was the original,
his original story.
And he really kind of
caught my imagination.
And for the first time in my
life, literally, I thought,
here's a character I
can build a series on.
Because he's a very complex guy
with a past that's
different than his present,
and a future that he hopes will
be different than his past.
He's kind of moving in
a certain direction,
and he's surrounded
by this world
that's really kind of
coming apart at the seams.
So, it's the story of a man
who's trying to learn
to be a good man
after a past that's not so good,
in a world that's collapsing.
In a world that cannot supply
in the values he
needs to move forward.
And that to me just seemed
like an endlessly
fascinating idea.
So, I wanted to put him up
against one of these guys
where he basically, you know,
the people who get in
his way get canceled,
but they get canceled
forever, you know.
And so you have a guy
who's kind of looking,
who has done some of this
wet work in the past.
He's done some of the
kind of evil things
that people have to do in
government and in espionage.
And now he's thinking, "No,
I wanna live a better life."
But he notices that
people around him
are starting to do
those kinds of things,
almost without any
conscience at all.
So basically this is
two men facing off.
I mean, if you picture
it as a movie poster,
it would just be these two
faces looking at one another.
Gerald Byrne and this
kind of English professor.
That's what he is now.
And he keeps telling
people, that's what I am,
I'm an English professor.
But he's an English
professor with a past
that's much more difficult.
So I wanted to put them
off against one another.
Person who believes in the
traditions of the past,
the art of the past,
the culture of the past,
who's trying to
build a personality
based on some of those
traditions and values,
against a guy who basically
has reached a point.
He's not a bad man, he's
just a man insulated
from the consequences
of his ideas.
And so I wanted these guys,
two guys, to face off,
and they face off with
a woman between them
who is really one of
the best characters
I think I've ever written.
He's just an actual good woman
who is married to this
guy, Gerald Byrne.
And the question is, how much
of what he's doing is she
involved in?
- You know, it's so
interesting that you
mentioned the way these people
become insulated and how
they think, because you know,
I've gotten to know
Peter Thiel quite a bit,
and I heard him give a talk once
where he said that "When
these guys go to Davos,
and to these massive meetings
where they're in
essence discussing
how to organize the world,"
he said that "No one's ever
representing the individual.
That it's always that, oh, it's
a corporation that's there,
and it's a bank that's there,
and it's this
conglomerate that's there.
No one is representing the guy
who has to put the gas in
the Volkswagen, no one."
So I would say he probably is
maybe the exception to the
rule, on that sort of thing.
But to broadly speak, it's
like what does Bill Gates,
why does he have the right to
tell us we have to eat bugs
while he's now the largest farm
owner in the United States?
- It is quite remarkable.
Remarkable the detachment
with which they exclude
themselves from their own rules.
You know, there is a reason
they built guillotines
in the old days.
And I think that these guys
kind of exemplify that reason.
I'm a very deeply opposed
to political violence,
but giving these guys a good
swift kick in the backside
would not be a bad idea.
I don't wanna kill anybody,
but just to humiliate
them a little bit
- Well,
now I know what
- would be a good thing.
- Clip Media Matters is
gonna find of today's show.
(laughing)
Well done Andrew.
- Bloodshed, I just
want my footprint
on the seat of their pants.
- Do you find that
sort of amazing though,
really like just at
a granular level,
that these people
have now infiltrated
every part of our lives?
Whether we know it or not,
whether it's because you
buy all your stuff on Amazon
or because Gates owns all the
land or whatever it might be,
that we're all holding
this in our pocket
and God knows who's in charge
of this thing at this point?
- You know, there are two things
that keep me from being amazed.
One is all throughout history
there have been
people like this.
People who think, that
have these global ideas
and they think that they
are going to impose them
on the world, and the world's
gonna be a better place.
Always a disaster
every single time.
But there's also something else,
the technological
age has raised people
who are essentially autistic
to the level of kings.
And these are guys
who are completely detached
from the inner life
of other human beings.
I don't know if you saw that
clip of somebody at Davos
saying we can make
medicines that we can track
after you take them.
And he said, imagine
the compliance.
Well that's a guy who
has lost all sense
that you and I have inner lives
that are equally
important to his.
And in fact, the homeless
guy on the corner
has an inner life that's
equally important to mine.
- I think you're talking
about Yuval, what's his name?
Yuval Harari I
think is his name.
- Yeah, I think
that's who it is.
Noah Yuval Harari,
something like that.
- I don't think that
was the guy in the clip,
but he's one of these
people definitely.
They can all understand
the inner lives of animals.
They love animals,
but they can't understand
the inner lives of people.
And I think that
the technological
age we're living in
has lifted those
people to new heights.
They've always been around,
but now they are the guy.
It's not the guy
who dug an oil well,
and then made so much money
that he could build
an oil business.
It's not that guy.
It's not the guy who
came from overseas
and built a movie studio, and
had his hands on the film,
and then could hire
other people to do it.
These are guys who deal
with little, you know,
Os and ones, and
really have never had
the experience of another
human being mattering to them
at the level that people
have to matter to you,
when you are in charge of
large areas of human beings.
- It's funny, do you
remember a couple months back
when Mark Zuckerberg
was introducing the
metaverse to everybody,
and he's in the
commercial himself,
and he's walking into
this alternative universe
and it's like, first off,
you're the guy who runs Facebook
who has screwed up so much
of how we feel about
each other these days,
and has caused parents
to hate children,
and friends to turn on each
other, and everything else.
You also seem like an automaton.
You don't even seem
like a full human.
And now I'm gonna follow you
into your crazy
alternate universe?
And yet we know that a
huge percentage of people
are gonna do it.
- Yeah, well, one of the things
that I think is important to
realize is that many people,
many more people than you
think, are mentally ill.
A larger percentage of people
than you think.
- Oh I think it's
quite a high number, actually.
- It's a high number, and
it wouldn't surprise me
if it were 50%.
- I'm on Twitter.
(laughing)
- Well, there you go.
I mean, it really is interesting
that they're not
dealing with life
in a very connected way.
You know, all this stuff about
the golden rule, you know,
do unto unto others as
you would have them do,
love your neighbor as yourself.
That kind of idea.
There's a reason for
that kind of idea.
It's not because you're a
good boy and you go to heaven
if you love your
neighbor like yourself,
it's because it
connects you to reality.
It connects you to the world
and to this infinite
pattern of human beings
interacting with each other,
which is all of the joy of life.
You get it in your family
with your children,
you get it in your marriage,
but also you can get it
in your neighborhood.
And all of that stuff is
being dissected and destroyed
by people who do not experience
the inner lives of others
because they're essentially,
at least morally,
I don't wanna make it
a medical diagnosis,
but morally autistic.
And I think as Zuckerberg
is a great example.
- Do you think there's
a way to reverse that?
I mean, I do sense
that there's gonna be a
real anti-technology revolt,
at some point within
the next decade.
I mean, it's just so obvious.
The level of censorship
and shadow banning,
and don't talk about
Hunter Biden laptop.
You can't question
this election.
You can question that one.
Like all the asymmetries
of it and inconsistencies,
I think on top of just the
general endless scrolling,
and what it's doing to
the dopamine in our brains
and all of this stuff.
I sense there's gonna be like
a real push against this.
Do you think that
that's probably right?
- Yes, I completely
agree with that.
And the reason is because
it's happened in the past
during the Industrial
Revolution.
These factories were built.
They destroyed families.
Suddenly children
who used to stay home
and help you with the farm,
were going off to the cities
to work in the factories
and never coming back.
Families were torn into pieces.
Women were deprived of
all the home industries
that made them a
powerful economic factor.
That's why feminism starts to
rise at exactly that moment.
Because suddenly women who
were called the distaff,
'cause they made all
the clothes, you know,
that was a tool you
used for making clothes.
That's a huge industry.
They made the food,
they planted orchards
and all these things.
Suddenly they had nothing
except raising children,
and they had lost
their place in society.
Well, over time,
governments started to say,
"Hey," you know, "actually
you can't put a six year old,
or an eight year old
in a blacking factory."
You know, "you can't
have children working.
You can't destroy
everything in your wake
just to make a bundle."
And they started to regulate it.
Years ago when they started
this censoring thing on Twitter,
and on Facebook. and
on Google and so on,
I said, "No, no, you have to,
you have to make regulations.
It's a new industry.
Every human interaction
is regulated by the law."
And conservatives were going,
"No, they must have
freedom of speech."
And I thought, "Absolutely not."
You know, these
guys are basically,
what do they call
'em, common carriers.
They're like the phone company.
If I'm on the phone to you,
and they operator comes on
and says, "Excuse me sir,
you can't say that to Dave
and Dave can't respond,"
you know, no, that
guy gets carried away
'cause there's a
regulation against that.
We need to do that now.
We're just catching up with it.
I feel it's happening.
It may happen in the
Supreme Court session.
Certainly there's
laws now in Texas
that have been
supported by courts
where the court
just said in Texas,
"No, they don't have a right
to violate free speech."
It's a new thing.
Almost everything
we're going through
is traceable back
to the internet,
in the same way that everything
during the reformation
is traceable back to
the printing press.
And so this is something
we have to grapple with
and come to terms with.
I'm hopeful just like you,
that as a generation grows up,
knows this stuff better
than the older generation.
They'll start to say, "Well,
we'll curtail it here.
We're gonna stop 'em here,
we're gonna do this this way."
And it'll start to work out
in a better way than
it is right now.
- So do you think that this
moment that we find ourselves in
between the Big Tech craziness,
and now just all the exposing
of all of the
political nonsense,
that this is sort of inevitable,
that maybe 20 years
of the internet
was going to have to get
us to a place like this
so that enough of us
could have that awakening
and then get to the
other side of it?
That it was gonna
happen no matter what?
- That's exactly what I think.
And I think that like so
much is ending right now.
I said this when Donald
Trump was elected.
This is not the
beginning of something.
It's the end of something
that will lead to the
beginning of something.
You know, it's the end of
the post World War II era.
It's the end of the Reagan era.
It's the end of
the Baby Boomapoc.
The baby boomers
are all gonna die.
I'm just hoping they
won't take me with them
as they go, when they go.
(laughing)
You know, and it
is the invention of
this brand new thing.
When you think about the
invention of the printing press
and then you have
the reformation,
you have the 30 years war,
you have the counter
reformation, you
have the inquisition,
you have all this
violence coming about
simply because suddenly
someone can read the Bible
and say, "You know what?
I don't think the Pope
is right about this."
Some clown in Germany can
read the Bible and say,
"You know, actually, this
doesn't actually sound
like what the pope is saying."
That's how things fall apart.
And that's what's happened here.
Essentially what Culvers
called the claricy,
this chattering classes
have suddenly had their
monopoly of information
taken away from them.
And so the counter reformation
is basically the
inquisition that's going on
is you're thrown off Twitter,
you're thrown off Facebook,
Google's only gonna show you
climate change information
that agrees with what the
elites want you to think.
Didn't work in the inquisition,
didn't work in the counter-ref,
it's not gonna work now.
Eventually this is the
democratization of information.
We're gonna learn
how to handle it.
We're gonna learn how
to sort misinformation
from information.
Basically, if it's coming
from the government,
it's misinformation,
and then everything else
is open to question.
But, you know, we'll
learn to sort it
and we'll stop them
from censoring us.
And I think ultimately
yeah, that'll smooth out.
- Let me ask you one,
someone on the personal side
of how we both go about
doing the political thing,
relative to what
you're talking about,
it's getting harder and harder
to find people on the other side
that are willing to have
these conversations.
I would say it's almost
impossible at this point.
Are you able to find
anybody to talk to,
to take the counterpoint
and do it without, you know,
murdering each other?
- In two ways I'm
able to do this.
First of all, older
people can still do it.
I still have discussions with
older people where, you know,
'cause I have a lot
of old liberal friends
who are like, "What
happened to you?"
And I'll sit down and
I'll explain to them
what happened to
me, and they'll go,
"Oh yeah, I kind of
feel some of that too,
even though I'm more," you know,
"I'm wedded to my Democrat
party," or whatever.
You know, we have
those conversations.
We have them in a friendly
way and intense way,
somewhat sometimes
with a friendly way.
But the other thing is,
is that there is now going
through the left, the Democrat,
the central left,
they're quietly appalled.
They're quietly appalled by
some of this gender stuff.
what's happening in schools.
They understand that
this shutdown over COVID
was a big mistake
and really hurt them.
They have kids, they see
their kids being hurt,
and they'll say it,
but they're afraid.
And that's what we
have to get past.
That's why The Daily Wire, you,
anybody who is willing to
bring on alternative voices,
and who's willing to take
the heat, is so important.
Because the people who
don't have our platforms,
the people who aren't
protected as we are
by the First Amendment,
and can be fired by HR
for not agreeing, you know,
with their stupid policies,
those are the people
who are afraid.
We need to bring 'em
out into the open.
We need to let them know that
they shouldn't be afraid,
and we need to fight the
powers that make them afraid.
And then I think we'll
be able to talk again.
- Do you think that
that fear thing
is maybe connected to
a spirituality deficit
within liberals, let's say?
I mean, you have an interesting
spiritual journey yourself.
You were born Jewish,
you're Christian.
But that liberals who
tend to be more secular,
they then for some reason, COVID
they were all about fear,
basically, overnight.
And now that's sort of
permeated through everything.
- Yeah, there's just
no question about this.
This is the other thing
that's always at the
core of everything.
You know, we have been
taught to think about history
without God in it.
So you know, we'll
say God is dead,
you know, and that's a
perfectly fair statement to make
comparing the Middle
Ages to the 19th century.
But we have to understand
that what that means is
he's dead in our
hearts, he's dead,
our churches are failing us.
It doesn't mean
he's actually dead.
And so we have to
start thinking about
what it is we're doing
here as human beings.
Because if what we're doing here
is trying to live as long
as we can before we die,
then when, you know,
Jake Tapper comes on CNN
and says, "No, you
must be afraid.
You must be fearful," then
yeah, we should be fearful.
'Cause as Andrew Cuomo said,
"What could be
worse than death?"
But when we start to say
"No, we're actually part
of a greater spiritual journey."
And sometimes just like the
guys who invaded Normandy Beach,
sometimes we have to face death
and even accept death
as part of that journey,
then you have a very different
way of looking at things.
I'm fortunate that
I'm like a, you know,
a chattering guy like you.
I'm a writer and all that stuff.
I don't often have
to dodge bullets
or run onto a beach being
sprayed by machine guns.
But I wouldn't for one
second restrain what I say
because people might cancel me.
I know that because
I've done it.
I've been kicked out
of Hollywood basically.
(laughing)
And you know, I would
never ever do that.
It's not because I'm brave,
it's because in
God I'm fearless.
As long as I'm in God, as
long as I'm centered in God,
I know that I just have
to do what's right,
and I will be okay
in the long run.
Even if that long run is eternal
and not within my lifetime.
So yes, when you lose that hook
into something
bigger than yourself,
everything becomes fear.
How can it be be anything else?
Because we're all just
these fragile little people
who are here today
and gone tomorrow.
And if we're not part
of something eternal,
what's the point of
ever putting your head
over the edge of the trench?
- It's so interesting because
when people come up to me,
like at the store or something,
and they'll be, "Dave,
you're so brave.
You're saying all the
things that I wanna say,"
and I always have two thoughts
at the exact same time.
One is, well, A, I'm not
being shot at, I'm not in war.
So I'm not brave to that extent
that it's just not
a real comparison.
And B, I don't know
that it's bravery
that causes me to say the
things that I believe.
Sometimes I think it's
just, I'm like, I'm nuts.
I guess maybe I'm just
kind of nuts, you know?
(laughing)
I don't know, everyone seems
to be afraid of this thing,
yet I seem to be one
of the people doing it.
I don't know, maybe I'm crazy.
I don't know if that
makes you brave.
- I always remind myself
that we do have an extra
layer of projection
because we speak for a living.
So we're protected by
the First Amendment
in ways that a guy who works
in the clothing industry,
or the car industry, is not
protected in the same way.
And they can say to him,
"You didn't sign the HR
paper saying that, you know,
a man can become a
woman, you're fired."
So, were a little
bit more protected.
But yes, I also think that
that is what the times require.
So it's people
like us who remain,
because that's what
the time required.
If you're not able to do that,
you're not gonna be
doing what we're doing.
- What do you think of
reformation for the Democrats?
Your old friends
that you can talk to.
What would it look like?
Like, what do you think
could happen over there
that would reverse the insanity?
Right, like to me right now,
there's a decent
fight on the right.
There's like, okay, are we
gonna go the Trump route?
Are we gonna go
the DeSantis route?
I think there's good
arguments for both.
Either they're gonna have
to figure it out on the DL,
or it's gonna
happen out publicly.
And I think either
one probably is fine,
but on the left it's
hard to figure out,
like, what are you
people gonna do
with this monster that is there?
- Yeah, see, I think
that the delusion
that the left is living under,
the nice people on the left,
and there are
many, many of them,
many good people on the left.
The delusion is that yes,
the people who are
butchering children
may have gone too far,
but there is a version of this
where that doesn't happen.
And that's not true.
I mean it's all one thing.
And, so, look, there is
something called liberalism,
which maybe supports more of
a welfare state, for instance,
than I would support.
I would like to see more things
done by private charities.
I would like to see the
great society dismantled.
I think it's been a disaster.
I think that all of the stuff
that people are
attributing to the police,
who have nothing to do with it,
really can be attributed
to the great society,
which destroyed black families,
and made black people dependent,
and basically funded all
kinds of bad behaviors
that have destroyed
black communities.
You know, I'd like to
see all of that go away.
But I can imagine a liberalism
that's sort of like Friedrich
Hayek says, you know,
"We need a little bit
of a welfare state
so people won't be
afraid to take chances,
and take risks, and
all that stuff."
If you can recreate
that liberalism,
that was the liberalism
that I grew up with,
yeah, then you'll have
sanity on the left again.
But either they're going
to follow these people
to the point where
their children are
taken away from them
because they won't
let them wear a dress,
or because they won't cut a
healthy girl's breasts off.
You're either gonna
follow those people,
or you're gonna have
to side with us.
And it's gonna be tough.
You know, that's another
reason, by the way,
where I think I have real
misgivings about Donald Trump,
because he offends the
sensibilities of those people.
And the people on
the right who say,
"Oh mean tweets, mean tweets."
Well, you know, human beings
are not logical creatures.
They don't necessarily say,
"Well that policy is working,
therefore I'm gonna take
this guy who I can't stand
and vote for him."
You know, politics
is partly showbiz,
and you've gotta be
appealing to these people
and convince them.
I think they'd vote
for Ron DeSantis.
I think there are
a lot of Democrats
who'd vote for Ron
DeSantis once they saw him.
- I'm getting a lot
of that on the DL.
from, people.
- Me too.
- The few that'll still
talk to me that, you know,
couldn't vote for Trump
or some of them maybe did,
but it was private, that they
could do the DeSantis move.
You know, it's interesting
when you mentioned that
about the welfare state, and
what it did to the black family
and all of that stuff.
But, you know, the
Hayek argument of like,
there could be some
sane version of this.
This is where I always quote
a great line from Thiel.
He always says, you know,
"If any of it worked,
I wouldn't be a libertarian."
But the human part of it,
once you get humans
into the machine,
this is Thomas Sowell has talked
about this a lot, you know,
you tell the government that
their stuff isn't working,
and they tell you we
need more money for it.
And then it just
- That's right.
- Expands the stuff
that's not working.
- Yeah, they never
give up their power.
You know, Jeremy Boreing the
guy who runs The Daily Wire,
he called me up when they said
15 days to slow the spread,
and he's a much
younger man than I am.
And he said "They'll
never open again."
And I laughed and I said, "15
days is not such a bad idea."
And I had to go back and say,
"You were basically right."
They will open again.
But, 15 days that becomes
two years, is not acceptable.
But that is the way the
government now works.
Didn't used to be like that,
but it's the way it works now.
- A huge percentage of
us seem to want more.
want more of the "Thank you
sir, may I have another,"
just more of the control.
I honestly think
that probably something
like 40% of the people,
it might be something
around there,
would be glad if all
the craziness came back.
And I think that maybe is
connected to a spiritual thing.
That they're just living
for nothing at the
moment, or something.
- Well, it goes back
to what I said before
about, like, connecting
with the inner lives
of other people, which is kind
of what I do for a living.
But it's also like my spiritual
practice is understanding
that I'm not talking to a face,
I'm talking to a human being,
whose inner life is
just as important.
You know, when you
lock people in a room
and they're suddenly saying,
"Oh you can be educated
online, you can work online,
you can see everybody online,"
you can't, you just can't.
And it's hiding away from life.
And I think as we said before,
I think there are
a lot of people
who are happy to
hide away from life,
cause they don't do life well.
And I think that that's
why so many people
are on antidepressants.
A huge number of people
think that they can drug
their way to happiness.
It never occurs to them to say,
it does occur to a few of them,
but it doesn't occur to
enough people to say,
"You know what,
that's not happiness.
Taking a drug and feeling
better is not happiness.
I've gotta find
another way to do this
so that I'm still
a human being."
And like I said before,
I think in the end
we're gonna divide
along those lines.
It's not gonna be
left and right,
It's gonna be human or inhuman.
It's gonna be drugged, or doing
yoga and spiritual practice.
It's going to be, you know,
cooking a baby in a box
and then having it
raised by a machines
or at the, you know,
daycare or whatever,
and saying, "No, we've
gotta form families.
If we don't form
families, we're nobody.
We have no government
of our own."
And that's where I think
the division's gonna come.
- This was gonna be a
complete non-sequitur,
but then you mentioned family,
so you get me to
the ending nicely.
Because we've talked
about this a bit before,
but most of my audience knows
your son Spencer Klavan,
who I just got his book
today too, it's downstairs.
And Spencer got married,
he happens to be gay.
He got married to a
dude a month or two ago.
Unfortunately I couldn't go
'cause Justin was born
that day, literally.
So I didn't get to
upstate you in the speech.
That's what I heard.
- I was so happy to where I
didn't have to follow you on,
it was like the last
thing I wanted to do.
- But, you're a conservative.
He lives in Nashville
in Tennessee.
Josh works at The Daily Wire.
These are conservatives.
They're not supposed
to like gay people.
You're supposed to
disown your son,
blah blah, blah, blah, blah.
And yet I sense it was
a pretty great day,
and life is good, and it
wasn't a lot of hatred.
- It was a lovely day.
And obviously I love Josh,
and I'm thrilled to have him
become part of my family.
I'm also thrilled to have
my son grow up in a time
when he doesn't
have skulk around,
or worry about the law coming
after him for who he is.
But that doesn't mean
we shouldn't be allowed
to talk about things
without being called names.
You know, there were
people at Spencer's wedding
who think that gay marriage
is the end of the world.
They came to the wedding
'cause they love Spencer,
and they love Josh.
As I said in my my toast,
I said, "You didn't lay
your principles aside,
you prioritized your love."
Once you do that, once you say,
"I understand that
you're a person,
and you wanna seek a happy life,
and you're not
responsible to me,
as long as you're
not hurting anybody,"
then you start to talk about,
obviously to just have
a sign outside your door
that says "love is love"
is as stupid as
it's possible to be.
There's obviously a difference
between a man and a
woman in a marriage,
and two men in a marriage,
or two women in a marriage.
We should be able
to talk about that.
We should be able to
talk about why nature
gives us men and
women as a model.
I think it does.
I think we are created
male and female.
Men and women are
meant to be together.
The fact that not everybody
can participate in that,
but sees that model
as a good thing,
I always thought it was kind
of a positive development.
- I do too, the first thing
that I did with Jordan Peterson
as part of The Daily Wire,
I did like a two hour
sit down with him
discussing just this.
And people were like,
"Oh, it seems like
Dave's saying somehow
that gay marriage isn't equal."
And it's like, no,
but there is a thing
that Western society
has been built on,
and you wanna give room
for decency and respect
and the things that are a
little bit on the margins.
But we should be able
to talk about that.
And the fact that you
just said, and I know,
'cause I spoke to Spencer
and Josh before the wedding,
that they invited people
who are not personally
okay with gay marriage.
It's like, do you think
that those people left
maybe a little bit
more open-minded?
Probably, as opposed to just
being called homophobes,
and not invited.
Then which way would
they be tilting?
- Well, exactly, and it's so
dumb, I mean, it's so dumb.
If your idea of
your philosophy is
there are people
who agree with me,
and then there are
people who are racist,
sexist, phobic of some
sort, you're an idiot.
I mean, you're an idiot.
All of us have ideas.
- But enough about
Kamala Harris.
(laughing)
- That's beyond idiocy.
But no, obviously if you're
gonna have a conversation,
you have to make room
for other people's ideas.
Even if those ideas
make you angry.
You have to be able to see
what people of goodwill,
some people are not
people of goodwill,
but people of
goodwill, disagree.
And you have to
let them disagree,
and you have to see
what they have to say.
I think that Christian right
has a lot to say about gender
that's not being heard,
that we should listen to,
because obviously the opposite
of what they're doing is a mess.
But, that doesn't
necessarily mean
I have to set people on fire
when I disagree with them.
It doesn't mean that I have
to destroy them or hate them.
And I think in this case,
I mean this was
something I was on board.
People always say that I changed
my mind because of Spencer,
but that's just
a simple untruth.
I always felt this
way, that being gay
is a very specific thing,
it's not a choice people make.
People have died
and been imprisoned
because they were gay.
It's not something you
wake up in the morning,
or you're a little
kid and think,
"I want to grow up to be gay,"
that's not the way it works.
It is something that people are,
and it comes with a
lot of ramifications
that are worth talking about
between people of good will.
I mean, when I hear
Christians say,
"Well it's okay as long
as they're celibate."
Yeah, it's okay with me as
long as you're celibate.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- How about you try
that and get back to me.
I think just a little bit of,
I hate to use the word love,
like it matters,
but it does matter.
A little bit of love between us,
a little bit of compassion
for each person's sensibility,
and then you can start
to trust one another
to discuss things at a
level beyond bile, you know,
a level beyond
sloganeering and hatred.
I think these are
important issues.
I think gender is a
hugely important issue.
I think it's a
hugely complex issue,
but that doesn't mean you
take a 16 year old girl
and cut her breasts off.
You have to have decades of
conversation and philosophy
before you even think about
making moves like that.
And we just don't do it anymore
because our press is so corrupt,
and our academies are so
corrupt, and our government,
and our businesses
are so corrupt,
that they have basically
shut the conversation down.
- Andrew, you are
a true professional
who knows how to close
down an interview.
You're a great gal, by the way.
And a "Strange Habit of
Mind" is on sale right now.
We will link to it down below,
and I hope to see
you soon, my friend.
- Always great to see you, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.